[Music]
strong museum in rochester new york is
also known as the national museum of
play more than half a million objects
are here
my name is chris bench i'm vice
president for collections at the museum
and it's chief curator our collections
are divided by category and here are
some of the people who are responsible
for them
nicholas ricketts is curator of board
games
in our collection
we have around 10 000 board games
and it parallels essentially american
history since the revolution
when you think in terms of games they
all tend to represent the areas in which
they were created it's a different way
of getting into the mindset of people
who lived 100 years ago
there's michelle parnet dwyer curator of
dolls
in this collection we have more than 15
000 dolls and it spans from the 18th
century to present day
dolls are special because of the way
that we connect with them we
project ourselves our hobbies our
interests our values towards
others when we look at the history of
dolls and how we've played with them it
shows that we connect
to people from the past in ways that we
might not have expected
martin reinhardt head of pinball and
arcade game collections
we have over 250 arcade machines and
over 100 pinball machines in the
collection
pinball
is real you can feel the way the game
plays you can feel the way the game
moves as
you're playing it
it's just in my nature to keep these
machines going they were made to last
five years in a commercial environment
and the fact that we have games that are
30 40 50 60 years old is amazing to me
[Music]
so i'm curator responsible for general
toys things like action figures and
yo-yos this collection has more than 70
000 objects
toys always reflect what's going on in
the world around them when it's economic
boom times construction toys are big
when the us is at war we see all sorts
of military and war toys
the toy collection is a wonderful
example of how times have changed and
people have changed over the years
play is really important it's an
integral part to who we are as human
beings only by understanding how play
has stayed the same and more importantly
changed over the years can we understand
how we've developed as people and how
we've played over the centuries
[Music]
you